yeah
上を受けてあーこれえええええ
今日はパリ1月マギーだけ予定 j 最後の夏はどうしてもどうしてもないとプロに
行きたいと言い続けて気づいた8月が終わってしまい落ち込んでいたが超ついな
これはなルールあもう鈴まあ
終わって大丈夫的で今回です愛知県やでラグーンな店舗さんにお邪魔させていただいて
おります上ちゃんと撮影するを取ってるから合法的に水着のお姉ちゃんと
ウェーハー
ほんとた交えてかつだよねけんぴを始めて始めたぜ怖いけどこれは社会経験というか
なくの終わりつもさあ涼しい者でも秋秋秋なんよないところでなんか盛り上がってるの
を想像してるところですよ
秋のはじまり夏の終わりぐらいに入ったナイトソールどんな感じなのかちょっと者が
すごい寂しいかもしれない誰も
いないかもしれないそんな中で行くナイトプールどんなさんなのか皆さんにお届け
しようと思いますピグらーーーっ
行くよ
[音楽]
はっきり言っ
ブーバーそりゃあし
[音楽]
me
d 灰ねーパニックがねえよバレてたんですよ
もう付けてミラーボールだけじゃねえっ面待ちでこれは回ってるんだか
海外でてもらうとプール丸かぶり付けなそうなプールものってプラマグがポイントで
ある
レイヤーわあああああ
名前山々待ったメンターパリでめっちゃマルケ
goo
ああああああ
wh
なんかもうプール秋田秋田はグラブないだわー
待て待て温めて寝るめっちゃで滑っ na
[音楽]
[拍手]
今日も大人気ですやっぱり得ない
[音楽]
me
完全囲まれはザバーって
わートンビですねこれはー
[音楽]
rar
goo
bc 2 h
par
nan
uh
tee
nara
ana
[拍手]
rar
goo
ani
ハワイ行ってきましたパリぴの泥をはじめ著書です
これが本物の恋ティ
すごいそれをインクレポレアードなくちゃ日本一男うがー1階すごい
じゃっすごいですねーバリ日ばかりで困るん
おもろいなでも強いみたいじゃ楽しい
じゃあ1回戻っ戻るクリステア
限りずっと居なくなったらと思ってならばゲーって言っちゃったんですねーよ
まだ本日は同じハンバーガーいう間に終わってるよねん
た w んけどま. rar
暴挙サーキッもっと5歳からさーああ
me
ああああああ
ええええええ
[音楽]
me
バッハ
いい加減前方を買ってペグ前にここで古い木製もファイターだ
mar
ああああああ
ぽ強いだぞ競ったバイバイ相撲も泣けちゃったよ
パター
rar
[笑い]
voodoo にょんっ
ブーバーし
car
th
ええええええ
e 7 a
てお疲れ様です
ですから2パースターって感じですよねやっぱり
[音楽]
まあそうなっちゃうわねぇ水着のんだなと思って
ドキドキしたんですけど直視できねーんだわそれはありませんでしょ
目をそらしちゃう絶対こうやってなんか逆にこっちが恥ずかしくないですからとかじゃ
無理言うだけで来年もまた
だと思いますいい夏になりましたありがとうありがとうございました